In this segment, we go through
another random incidence
example, one that does not
involve the Poisson process,
but a much simpler
arrival process.
We do this for two reasons.
One is because of the
simplicity of the example,
perhaps the intuition will
be a little more transparent.
And the second reason
is to illustrate
that we're dealing with
a phenomenon that's
not specific to the
Poisson process,
but is much more general.
The example is as follows.
We have an arrival
process, in which
arrivals happen at random.
And the consecutive
interarrival times
are independent, identically
distributed, random variables.
However, unlike the
Poisson process,
these interarrival times are not
exponential random variables.
But instead, we assume
that they are either
5 or 10 minutes with
equal probability.
So we have an arrival.
The next arrival may
happen five minutes later.
The next arrival may again
Then maybe we get an
interarrival interval of length
10, then maybe another
10, followed by one
of five, and so on.
What is the expected value
of the kth interarrival time?
Well, an interarrival time is
with probability 1/2 of length
five and with probability
1/2 of length 10.
So the average
interarrival time is 7.5.
Now, you show up
at a random time.
And by random we
mean a time that's
completely uncoordinated
with the arrival process.
You show up at
some point in time,
and you look at the interarrival
interval in which you fall.
And you're interested
in the length
of that particular
interarrival interval.
What is the probability that
you fall inside a five minute
interarrival interval?
Since intervals of
length five are as likely
as intervals of length
10, in the long run,
there's going to be roughly
as many five minute intervals
as there will be 10
minute intervals.
On the other hand, the
10 minute intervals
occupy twice as much
space on the real line.
And for this reason, it
is 2 times more likely
that you will fall in a
10 minute interval rather
than a five minute interval.
In other words, the probability
of falling in a five minute
interval is going to be 1/3.
Whereas the probability of
following in a 10 minute
interval is going to be 2/3.
For this reason,
the expected length
of the interarrival
interval that you
get to see when you arrive is
equal to, with probability 1/3,
you see a five.
And with probability
2/3, you see a 10.
And this number evaluates
approximately to 8.3,
which is indeed larger than 7.5.
The conclusion from this
example is similar to the one
that we had for the
Poisson process.
Although the average
interarrival time
is 7.5, when you show
up at a random time
you are more likely to
fall in a larger interval.
And for that reason,
on the average,
you will be seeing longer
interarrival intervals.
The calculations that we carried
through in that simple example
can be generalized for
more general arrival
processes, called
renewal processes.
In a renewal process, once more
the consecutive interarrival
times are independent,
identically distributed,
random variables.
But they have a
general distribution.
For this case, there's
a formula again
that tells us the
length or the expected
length of the interarrival
interval that you get to see.
But the main message
from this example
is that it does make a
difference how you sample,
how you choose what to
watch and what to measure.
It makes a difference
whether you
decide to measure the kth
interarrival time and it's
average value or to
decide to measure
an interarrival
time that's chosen
by showing up at a random time.
The two methods of sampling
give you different results.
And we will see
next a few examples
that have this
particular flavor.